Allora domenica andiamo al Vai
cominciamo subito è maggio giugno
Insomma abbiamo lavorato tutta la
settimana quindi ci concediamo una
domenica al mare
scegliamo una spiaggia selvaggia Wild
Insomma quindi quello che ci piace ma
con pochi ombrelloni carichiamo in
macchina bambini il labrador di casa la
nonna Il canarino i proiettile bere
tutto che neanche la Protezione Civile e
iniziamo questo viaggio della speranza e
andiamo in spiaggia quindi Un'ora due
ore di macchina famiglia arriviamo nella
nostra spiaggia preferita a questo punto
facciamo una serie di azioni tipiche che
facciamo tutti quindi scarichiamo il
nostro accampamento
mettiamo frighetti ombrelloni di turno
mettiamo la nonna Mi raccomando lo
liberiamo Il nostro cane che
cicciottello ci ha aiutato a levare i
bambini appena liberiamo diventano
levriero di avere neanche bene
e liberiamo i nostri figli Armati Fino
Ai Denti quindi secchielli palette
sacchetti che neanche lo sbarco in
Normandia che iniziano a darmi a
dragarmi la spiaggia allora
queste a
diciamo forse non abbiamo mai pensato
che le stiamo facendo E soprattutto non
abbiamo mai pensato che ogni singola
azione che vi ho descritto può avere un
effetto può avere un effetto negativo
molto negativo O un effetto positivo o
anche migliorativo andiamolo a vedere
allora ripercorriamo un attimo con la
mente che noi facciamo arriviamo in
Spagna in piazza trasferiamo iniziamo a
scaricare tappetini per tutto e
allestiamo il nostro campo base che cosa
abbiamo combinato ne abbiamo già
combinata una abbiamo fatto un
malanuccio abbiamo spiaccicato queste
simpatiche per piante che vivono in
spiaggia questi fiorellini di cui non ci
siamo neanche mai accorti Tra l'altro
nessuno ce l'ha detto e ci abbiamo messo
sopra proprio il progetto e la nonna
anche per schiacciarle bene Allora
queste piante hanno una funzione in
realtà importantissima perché con le
loro ricchette con le loro corpi proprio
fermano la sabbia la sabbia che il vento
e le mareggiate soprattutto d'inverno
sparano verso l'interno i grandi di
sabbia che vengono proprio fermati da
Queste piante Questa si chiama Rocchetta
per esempio di mare e quindi hanno una
funzione fondamentale quella di tenere
dura la spiaggia di permettere proprio
le dunette di rimanere di resistere e
quindi creano la spiaggia sono piante
terra formati e le abbiamo spiaccicate
primo guada dopodiché abbiamo liberato
il nostro la nostra laurea per
buonissima in casa che non sia mai mossa
un angioletto appena la liberiamo lei si
ricorda di essere un predatore di
derivare dai lupi Quindi inizia a
pattugliare ci ascolta più la chiave per
favore inizia a pattugliare la spiaggia
E immancabilmente è nella sua natura
inizia a cercare le creature della
spiaggia certo gli animaletti eccetera e
trova immancabilmente che cosa i nidi e
i pulcini di una serie di uccelli che
nidificano sulla spiaggia ce li
acquatici specie molto rari che sono
evolute proprio per dire nella spiaggia
quindi solo lì possono fare il nido
pensate che questi animali ci sono in
tutta la costa italiana ovunque voi
andiate in spiaggia dalla sabbia ai
sassolini e possono stare solo lì loro
come si vede puntano molto sublimettismo
stanno immobili
[Musica]
sono color sabbia
muscoli non si possono difendere dalla
predazione che il nostro cane fa se le
mangia ce lo porta anche come première
si porta il pulcino spiaccicato in
particolare questo è il fratino che
il poveretto lui Ogni nel Mediterraneo
ogni dieci anni Cala del 50% della sua
popolazione quindi tra 10 anni e 20 anni
sarà e
stinto e nidifica sulle spiagge quindi
secondo maluccio stiamo estinguendo un
animale
vediamo poi la terza cosa che abbiamo
fatto la nonna non si muove va bene però
i bambini Sì Cariola i bambini perché
siamo venuti con i nipotini figli e gli
amici che iniziano a raccogliere dalla
spiaggia tu non solo conchiglie ci
mancherebbe ma granchi legnetti
qualsiasi cosa di solito
riempiono i secchielli ci riempiono il
baule della macchina sabbia dappertutto
portiamo a casa tranne poi martedì la
nonna quanto Butta via tutto quindi una
seduta e che cosa abbiamo combinato che
cosa hanno combinato le loro manine a
nord destrutturato la spiaggia perché
appunto le spiagge Hanno bisogno di
queste piccole piante che tengano la
sabbia ma la sabbia poi per restare per
costruire le dunette ha bisogno di
qualcosa di duro quindi legnetti
conchiglia anche i legni più grossi che
poi noi usiamo per fare la roba ai ferri
eccetera quindi abbiamo diciamo
un quarto d'ora ce l'abbiamo un po'
disintegra visto la spiaggia
selvaggia Wine per la quale andiamo
proprio lì che ci piace molto e con un
danno anche che si protrae addirittura
ad una specie o si protrae negli anni
perché perderemo questa spiaggia nel
giro di qualche anno benissimo Non lo
sapevamo adesso che lo sappiamo quindi
consapevolezza Cosa possiamo fare
possiamo mutare un po' le stesse azioni
che abbiamo fatto buttarle un po' di
modo e ottenere passare da degli effetti
negativi a degli effetti estremamente
positivi vediamo cosa allora no
schiacciamo le piante molto semplice
stiamo attenti quando andiamo nelle
spiagge libere nelle spiagge così
selvatiche dove ci accoppiamo dove
mettiamo le nostre cose rispettiamo
questi fiore quindi perché sono
fondamentali per tornare i prossimi anni
in spiaggia teniamo il cane al
guinzaglio tra aprile e maggio e giugno
e basta lì insomma il periodo
primaverile voi da pasto in avanti così
lui eviterà Insomma di estinguere una
specie di saldiamo dall'estinzione delle
specie e insegniamo i nostri figli a
oltre che a prendere dal mare
dall'ambiente anche a dare l'ambiente
qualcosa quindi prendi una conchiglia ma
portati a casa anche una bottiglia
scendiamogli a raccogliere Magari solo
le conchiglie più belle se proprio
dobbiamo raccoglierle ma anche a portar
via la plastica bottiglie di plastica
tappi vetro Nord Mi raccomando ci si
taglia Perché Perché sottraendo la
plastica da liquido plastica non andrà
in mare quindi non diventerà
microplastiche che poi e la catena
alimentare e ce le mangiamo Ci rivediamo
nei prossimi anni intossicandoci Ecco
quindi che semplici azioni che noi
facciamo sempre alle quali non abbiamo
pensato possiamo montarle e fare
diventare da negative a molto positive
addirittura
bene Adesso abbiamo fatto i nostri due
tre ore di malanni in spiaggia Cosa
facciamo Andiamo a mangiare quindi
ristorante abbiamo scelto un ristorante
Il prezzo medio basso che siamo in tanti
bambini parenti eccetera e ci sediamo a
tavola ristorante canne lo sappiamo
evidentemente uno solo pesce siamo al
mare ristorante di pesce meno ravioli
risotto di pesce e pane risotto per
tutti colorata magari Esatto benissimo
anche qua quando inforchiamo la prima
forchettata di riso stiamo già
combinando con dei malanni ai quali
giganteschi Tra l'altro ancora più
grandi questi vediamoli un attimo
insieme Allora prima cosa che pesce c'è
nel riso che stiamo mangiando tatto il
prezzo che noi stiamo pagando di questo
risotto sicuramente è pesce allevato in
mare in negli allevamenti industriali in
mare che ci sono in giro per tutti i
mali del mondo come il salmone che
compriamo questo pesce Viene nutrito con
cibo artificiale quindi la carne
gli si danno anche molte medicine perché
stando tutti insieme e poi li ammalarsi
quindi già il prodotto di partenza non è
un granché tutti questi prodotti
inquinano anche quella parte di mare
dove ci sono i pesci poi i pesci vengono
pescati imballati Stiamo producendo
plastica li dobbiamo trasportare quindi
consumo di petrolio sostanzialmente
tutta la filiera dello spostamento del
cibo che produce inquinamento in ogni
passaggio
industriale costa poco a basso prezzo e
quindi va subito in concorrenza con i
pescatori e produttori di pesce delle
nostre zone Quindi la prima forchettata
di risotto di pesce abbiamo già generato
un effetto che mi va a finire fino
nell'Oceano Indiano bene detto ciò il
riso il riso che stiamo mangiando
è sicuramente dato il prezzo prodotto in
un altro continente probabilmente in
Asia o in Africa in America in queste
zone Chiaramente la produzione del riso
spessore molto attenta magari come in
Europa alle sostanze chimiche che si
usano per cui già il prodotto di
partenza è un po' inquinato
le risaie ovviamente dobbiamo prodotto
inquinano tutta l'acqua circostante per
essere state create sono state
bonificate zone umide danno alla
biodiversità sono una catastrofe
viene raccolto viene imballato quindi di
nuovo plastica viene portato da noi
Quindi di nuovo tutta la filiera
protezione CO2 utilizzo petrolio Che
spostamenti arriva sul mercato italiano
quando arriva da noi ha un prezzo basso
troppo concorrenziale rispetto agli
italiano e quindi cosa generiamo
generiamo che gli esecutori italiani
stanno progressivamente abbandonando la
coltivazione del riso Le superfici
coltivate a riso tradizionalmente da
secoli in Italia basti pensare a Novara
a Vercelli il Delta Oristano No Stanno
diminuendo progressivamente quindi i
visitatori italiani stanno abbandonando
questa produzione che alla produzione di
eccellenza nostra quindi ecco
semplicemente mangiando un risotto di
pesce non consapevole chiamiamolo così
stiamo generando una serie di effetti
all'ambiente all'economia al paesaggio
proprio per tutto
bene e io cosa posso farci io posso
farci che posso comprare il cibo locale
mangiamo locale chiediamo al ristorante
compriamolo I nostri prodotti Se
facciamo l'esempio del riso se noi
compriamo riso nostro del Delta della
pianura padana italiano che cosa
otteniamo otteniamo Ecco di nuovo quindi
cambiamento di un'azione da molto
dannosa a molto positiva otteniamo
almeno tre ottimi risultati
aiutiamocitori nostri che mantengono
quindi l'economia poi Loro mantengono un
paesaggio un paesaggio tipico di secoli
quello era anche dei film Riso amaro con
Gassman con le mondine che che lavorano
il riso Quindi fa parte proprio della
nostra cultura della nostra tradizione e
stiamo aiutando anche la biodiversità
stiamo aiutando anche delle specie
animali tipo L'Airone rosso che era la
roba felice per gli antichi che proprio
mangiano all'interno delle risaie
essendo scompa spesso le paludi d'acqua
dolce nei secoli si è riadattato a
vivere nelle risaie Quindi anche qua un
risotto consapevole mi va a non solo
togliere tutta una serie di effetti di
inquinamento e di danni ambiente ma al
contrario mi va aiutare l'economia
l'ambiente è il paesaggio
anche il pesce il pesce che noi andiamo
a prendere probabilmente se lo compriamo
locale è un pesce che è stato allevato
magari nelle mani da pesca della nostra
costa che sono degli ambienti creati
dall'uomo da secoli molto importanti
fanno parte del paesaggio delle nostre
aree Il pesce è ovviamente a chilometri
zero sostanzialmente quindi porta la
filiera meno inquiniamo e più il pesce
di qualità e soprattutto sosteniamo
anche moltissima biodiversità
fenicotteri Ve l'ho messo qua vi
ricordate sono animali che vivono quasi
esclusivamente dentro a queste Valli
Quindi anche qua a seconda dell'orata
che io vado a comprare sto addirittura
aiutando un paesaggio e una parte della
nostra cultura ma anche i molluschi le
cozze e le vongole assolutamente se noi
compriamo cozze e vongole fasolari
ostriche tutto quello che la costa
italiana produce invece comprarlo magari
dall'estero stiamo aiutando migliaia di
famiglie
persone che arrivano su questo stiamo
aiutando il mantenimento di un paesaggio
e stiamo mangiando anche il cibo più
sano quindi gli effetti delle nostre
Piccole scelte in una domenica di maggio
possono cambiare assolutamente il mondo
ma senza bisogno di andare fino al mare
in primavera possiamo fare anche piccole
azioni da casa nostra quotidiani non ci
abbiamo pensato diciamo la
consapevolezza in ogni piccola scelta
poi ci porta a cambiare dobbiamo andare
al fioraio anche qua è una domenica è
Pasqua dobbiamo comprare i fiori perché
il vicino ha messo tutti i fiori sul
balcone a meno che noi li mettiamo Ok
innaffiater direi che non fate con mia
moglie e
che i fiori andiamo a comprare Allora
noi sappiamo ancora i gerani o le
Primule No oggi alle prime sono piante
africane quelle lì piene di farfalline
insetti che arrivano dall'Africa e che
poi vanno a creare problemi alla nostra
agricoltura
compriamo invece le piante officinali
perché no sono belle profumate fanno
parte della nostra del nostro paesaggio
della nostra cultura come la lavanda il
timbro rosmarino ma soprattutto hanno un
effetto
fondamentale sostegno aiutano gli
insetti promobil cioè tutti quegli
insetti che impollinano i fiori quindi
le api le farfalle ma anche le api per
prime attenzione le zanzare sono i più
grandi impollinatori di fiori del mondo
quindi Pensateci anche questa cosa
Fatemi beccare
È utile quindi anche semplicemente
mettendo
sulla finestra della cucina anziché un
Geranio stiamo cambiando moltissimo
perché le api è stato dimostrato se
scomparissero nel giro di qualche anno
porterebbero l'umanità all'estinzione
Perché le api vanno a collinare le
piante che noi mangiamo e le piante che
noi andiamo da mangiare ai nostri
animali quindi senza le api
l'alimentazione umana non esisterete
aiutiamole Allora mettiamo dei vasetti
di lavanda sul nostro balcone
Ecco quindi ogni tua piccola azione ogni
tua piccola scelta che vai a fare
soprattutto quando mangi quando fai la
spesa qualcuno diceva che tu vai
veramente a votare quando fai la spesa
in base a quello che hai nel carrello
ogni tua assicurazione cambia il mio
futuro cambia il nostro futuro Quindi
con più consapevolezza Pensa ai ceci